this great country belongs to the people  of myanmar  and the european union stands ready to  be your partner and your  in the journey ahead  this task force is not  one occasion it is the beginning of the  work that we will do  in the days weeks months and years to  come  i can now proudly say that  the current socio-political and economic  situation  in our country is better than  a year ago  a year from now the situation will be  much better as time progresses the  situation will get better and petty  while we are aware that many challenges  lie ahead  we are convinced that with your support  we will find a way to overcome them  we decided really to  to strengthen our aid for two years we  took an unprecedented decision to come  to 150 million euros that means 75  million euro a year that is a big amount  for this region  you